samantha what up so my older brother is
two years older than me
uh he's been using methamphetamine for
about the last five years that we know
oh it's so hard yeah i'm sorry
and thank you um so
i've watched as his life is just
completely degraded
uh you know first he lost his job in his
home
then he was charged with felonies and
recently his marriage
and now his three children um and i do
carry a lot of guilt
uh about the children because
he voluntarily surrendered them to cps
on my advice
because they were not in a good
situation um anyways it's been a long
uh and hard five years watching this and
i think i've become a little hardened to
the situation and then
sick of hearing how much of a victim he
says he is
but my question for you is how do i set
boundaries that protect my family and my
heart without completely isolating my
brother and appearing heartless
so how do you feel like you tell me
about how you feel heartless
well you know he'll call me in
situations um
and you know they're always really long
stories that you would just never even
believe what happened to him
and you know he never asks me for money
or anything like that we live in
different states
um but you know it's hard for me not to
say like well
you did because everything is always
everyone else's fault you know he always
plays the victim my wife kicked me out
my wife did this to me
yeah you know this person stole my stuff
and it's just always the same story i've
asked him several times like are you
tired yet like aren't you tired of where
you're at
and then he feels attacked and says i
don't understand him and
you know i'm a prosecutor and my
husband's a police officer and oh
sweet yeah we we know exactly what this
looks like and so for me i'm just like
you know i i want to be there for him
particularly because i'm still really
involved in my niece's life his children
so
give me that language what or paint me a
picture of this
what does really involved mean
with my nieces no when you say you want
to be involved with your brother what
does that mean
pay me a picture of that
well i want to be able to listen to him
and know what he's going through
you know it's a double-edged sword of
whenever
i do talk to him it's you know i feel
like i'm his emotional dumping ground
yep and i take that on and i know it
affects the way that
you know i am around my family i have
two young children and my husband
and um so i know i take that on and
internalize it but i don't
want to say hey i don't want to talk to
you anymore you can't
call me ever because then i you know
he's homeless and lives out in the
desert so then i always
in the back of my mind i'm like is my
brother alive is he safe
right um so here
i hate this for you and i i i doubly
hate it because i've been there
um not with my brother but i've got
people that i love um
and that i've been friends with and
connected to for years and years and
years who've struggled with math
and meth you know this i'm just i'm
saying this out loud for those who
listen
meth takes your soul from the inside out
and it almost um
it's like how a sock can be pulled
inside out you just watch somebody you
love just
i just can't describe it other than i
just feel like someone just you're
watching them get sucked into a black
hole backwards
and um you know they're in there
somewhere but there's so many
layers and occasionally the layers get
thin
the light can get through and they'll
pick up the phone and they'll call you
and you know what i'm you you sam
samantha like you know like right
and you hear them in there and you
answer that phone and you so bad want
this to be the call
and it never is right and then you find
yourself 45 minutes later and they're
telling you some story about
i was just going there for a quick
minute because i had to pick up a chat
because i did a
quick painting job which you know is
absolutely not what happened
and then it turns into a thing and a
thing and a thing and um
somebody's yeah somebody's still s and
then suddenly like
i find myself my hands are clenched my
heart's beating fast i'm so annoyed i
just want to hang up
and then i get my own game like guilt
and shame
spiral right that oh you don't even love
so and so
man i've been there and i hate that for
you
here's what i ultimately did and had to
do
and it this is just my n equals one
experiment it's worked out in my world
okay so this is the best i can tell you
because meth is so hard
um the first one is
i did come out with some boundaries
saying i i don't want to hear any more
of your drug stories
okay you can call me anytime i love love
talking to you
but i will not i'm not going to
entertain any more drug stories
i don't want to hear about those
adventures um
and it may take one or two times to like
set us up
stop i've already told you and this
isn't a calm conversation this isn't in
that
in a um mannequin right
yeah you know what i'm talking about
yeah it's not when the i call it when
the weed eater's going right when it's
just
not in that moment because they can't
hear anything in that moment right
and um but i'm not gonna hear any more
drug stories
i love to hear about how you're doing
where you're living how's the desert
right
and one of my most common responses
is i'm so sorry i love you that's it
where i made i think the most long-term
impact was i wrote a lot of letters
and people who listen to the show know i
say that a lot and here's why
when somebody's dealing with criminal
activity when someone's especially
dealing with any sort of addiction
drugs um pornography whatever the thing
is right
is whenever somebody even approaches
that addiction
every wall every piece of armor comes
flying up you know this you're a
prosecutor right
yeah um what a letter let somebody do
is it gives them something to go back to
and go back to and go back to
so their initial like when you say
aren't you just tired yet then the boom
all the
all the walls come up all the attacks
the arrows just start flying towards you
and you're like what did i do what did i
do
yeah right exactly when you have a
letter
they read that letter and they get one
paragraph in
or your brother i won't say they your
brother's gonna read one one paragraph
in
boom all the walls gonna go up he's
gonna start shooting arrows be shooting
at a piece of paper
and he may throw that paper away and
then next month he's gonna get another
letter from you
and he may do it again over time he's
gonna know two things
she kept writing me she kept sending
something
and the second thing is eventually he's
going to read a whole letter and be like
she sucks who does she think she is
fancy lawyer
but then one day he's going to read that
same letter again another day's going to
be that same letter again
and over time kind of like how water
just drips through limestone it's gonna
make its
way down and that pool down there will
get deeper and deeper and deeper
and you know as well as i do um the
other end of meth
is usually one of two things right
somebody like you said just gets
exhausted and says enough's enough and
they're gonna do the hard work and get
cleaned up
or it's got a really tragic ending and
that's where you have to do the hard
stuff right so we just talked about your
relationship there
you have to make sure you got really
good boundaries at home and i had to do
some work on myself
what i found in myself was i had my own
addictive stuff i just got paid for mine
right because mine's culturally
acceptable right i went to grad school
not saying you went to law school but
maybe right um
i did come up to seattle to get away
from
stuff happening in las vegas there you
go right you nailed it
um so i worked with a lot of law
students
who once they took a breath realized
they were running too
they're just running towards something
that the world said is going to make you
some money
but addiction is addiction as addiction
is addiction running from traumas
running from trauma is running from
trauma
right now if you have to pick math or
law school go to law school for god's
sake right but
there is something about us doing our
own work on ourselves
i got two phds for crying out loud don't
tell me i wasn't running for something
right
so yeah um we're all running most of us
and i had to do my own work which then
made
those boundaries easier for me once i
wasn't feeling so guilty all the time
once i didn't feel like i was my job to
make sure somebody else was doing okay
and purchasing a pair right all that
stuff
man then i could breathe and i could
just say i'm so sorry i love you
and when there was some wild story about
somebody broke into my trailer i finally
got a trailer from this guy named tom
for a
hundred dollars and then but somebody
he's like man i'm so sorry
i love you and i didn't have to solve it
i didn't have to
you know what i mean and it just gave me
so much peace and then one by one over
the course of five years 10 years 15
years
i've got great great relationships with
every single one of those people
and my again mine's a a fairy tale right
i didn't have anybody die i didn't have
anybody fall off
all the way off where they couldn't come
back and can i be real honest with you
into vulnerable world there were some
seasons when
some of my friends who people i loved
were caught in addiction and they called
me out on my crap too
right yeah they would occasionally drop
like oh you think you're better than me
i'd be like no and then i'd get up and
hang up the phone and i think
why do i think i'm better than somebody
struggle right i had to deal with my own
stuff
right and so that relationship went both
ways
for a long long time of course you carry
the the burden of that on your shoulders
right you carry the most of it but
um yeah i mean him and i we definitely
talk about
those things because you know he'll say
you don't understand or it must be nice
to say that in your war
pals um and so we've talked about those
things and you know i've told them i'm
never going to apologize for where i'm
at i worked hard to get here
and you don't get to make me feel guilty
about that and so let me tell you this
for him he is dragging you
into deep deep muddy water
and so when an addict comes at you and
says
it must be nice in your warm house
that's when you can just simply because
that sets off your alarm right that sets
you like
hey listen buddy i and don't respond to
that attack
just say i'm so sorry it's cold
i love you and that's that i'm not going
to get in the mud with you i'm just not
i'm not going to give you that
and folks who come up in in trauma
systems foster
folks who come up in a messy childhood
man when somebody wants to drag you into
a fight i'm coming baby right
what happens is you end up in a fight
that you can't win
they don't want to fight you anyway it's
the only language they have
and you both end up disgusted and
exhausted and covered but
it solves nothing right so that simple
oh it must be nice you know yeah it is
nice here
i'm sorry it's called where you are
that's it end of the sentence
right i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
receive a tax from an addict i'm just
not because i know that's not where
their heart is
i know there's different parts of their
brain hollering out at me it's not them
it's not in their soul
so be it right and sam i know
samantha i called you sam like we're
bros sam
um i know no no that's so hard
and i can be you can be honest here
i'm willing to bet you carries a little
bit extra shame because of your job
you're a prosecutor
you see your brother's face every day
when you go to work
you're a thousand miles away from him
you see his face every day when you go
to work
your husband sees his face every day as
a police officer when he goes to work
and that makes it extra hard that makes
it extra extra hard
do the work on yourself draw those firm
boundaries when the helicopter is
quiet right when the when the weed
eater's off
don't listen to anymore don't be a
dumping ground anymore
and just simply respond with i'm so
sorry it's cold
so sorry you're hungry and make sure you
get on the letter riding wagon
when you're when the when the light
finally shines through the shutters in
in your brother's heart
he's gonna see that stack over in the
corner of those letters
that sam kept sending kept sending kept
sending kept sending
oh we'll be thinking about you samantha
i've been there it's uh so hard